yeah and for glenn otto we'll take a
look at his season numbers five starts
the numbers don't look that good but
among those five stars were a couple of
really good starts where he had good
command
and marshes aboard to set the table
today well he's really good on breaking
ball especially that lower third staying
with it using the big part of the field
line drive
right center so marsha board and that'll
bring up shohei ohtani and that makes
this shohei's first plate appearance
with the men on in his last dozen trips
to the plate
1-1 pitch to shohei and that wins past
solac who's at second base today and the
angels have something cooking just two
at-bats into the game
marsh coming around to score shohei to
third where he's safe and rbi triple for
shohei ohtani one-nothing angels
99th rbi eighth triple
he goes you know i'll avoid a glove on
this one i'll just hit a rocket direct
field for a triple by the way that's
nine wins on the mound 156 strikeouts
but eight triples
for showing ohtani this incredible good
opportunity now to add on now for
derrick washington his rbi total he's at
91.
chopper that's gonna get a run home
right over hernandez on into left center
field two nothing halos three straight
hits open the ball game for los angeles
oh try it again the 2-2 pitch
and a curveball swung out and missed he
strikes out mayfield second out of the
inning first strikeout this afternoon
for otto taylor ward the banner now for
the angels
that one's hit forward into the gap in
left center field it's going to score
walsh easily going to try it with rojas
he'll score without a play at the plate
four-nothing angels yeah 15th double
this season taylor ward boy he's come
back and he's come back strong three
hits in his two games he's coming back
up with the angels
there's another base hit
and there's another run
ward is going to score in front of the
throw at the plate
five-nothing angels well for alex cobb
his last start came on thursday against
the astros he didn't get a decision in
the three to two angels win
also 26 doubles two triples it's this
one sharply out to right field
it takes the two out single
garcia running and the throw off line
bounces away from renjifo and for dolis
garcia that is his 16th stolen base just
trying to be quick to get through the
inning
gets a call with a fastball solace rung
up and two are left stranded in the
bottom of the first 5-0
and there were two away now for jared
walsh more impressive still that one's
headed for the gap the other way it
splits calhoun and peters jarrod on his
way into second halfway to the cycle
33rd double attention to home runs in
the rbi but 33 doubles
the payoff pitch swung on and grounded
to short
charged by hernandez throw to first in
time
the innings over
no runs a hit
one left started the count 3-0 now he's
at a full count of brock holt the 3-2
pitch home
is in for recalled strike three and holt
knew it snuck the fastball in there two
strikeouts for cobb
here comes the pitch
that's looped in the air short left
field coming on hard is ward and he'll
have to play it on a hop as jonah heim
dunks one in down the left field line uh
two out single
base runner now for yani hernandez
this one lined out into left field that
gets down for a base hit legarres
gathers it up i'm getting aggressive
heads for third he's in there and going
to second base is hernandez and so the
rangers again with two outs
in the inning trying to put a little
something together
he's gonna get out of this unscathed
this two are left stranded for the
second straight inning it's the five
nothing angels
yeah he took b the splitter
and gets the strikeout that was his best
one of the game that had a great drop to
it started right at the lower part of
the strike zone and ended up almost in
the dirt
good follow through with that splitter
for alex cobb so the rangers have a base
runner with two men out here in the
bottom of the third trailing five to
nothing for nick solac
this ball is ripped into center field a
base hit for solac
marsh charges picks it up lobs it in
toward third low will stop at second so
solac wastes no time
in turning around that sinking fastball
and the rangers now have been at first
and second with two away for dj peter
oh for two so far with runners in
scoring position today and peters
hammers this ball deep center field back
to the wall gone
there's your big bang theory there you
go
and maybe dj is the one to get it done
boy he put a charge in that fastball
[Applause]
there's another knock for jared walsh
three for three feeling it today the
last two at bats especially he's rocking
it the other way
roller to third block bare hands gets it
the first not in time
despite a great effort mayfield has a
hustle single in the fifth so still
runners at first and second with two
gone now and that will bring up juan
logaris two balls and two strikes to
count to legarres and a bouncing ball
base it back up the middle walsh is
being waved around to score no play at
the plate and it's a six to three angels
lead here's the notice he has singled
and struck out and the base hit right
here could give him his 89th rbi and a
new club rookie record 3-2 pitch
and that ball hit well deep out to right
field it is gone
number 31 for the rookie adulies garcia
he's made it a one-run game
he's just set the rookie record for
homers and rbis in rangers franchise
history
[Applause]
heckhead did not go well there's a base
hit
three singles
or rather
oh and shohei into second base
forget about the single it's going to be
scored a two base hit for ohtani 26
doubles now for show hey
good strike three called stassi down
looking inning is over angels leave a
couple
hot shot the third great play by
mayfield throw to first in time to get
him wow
the rangers might want to look at this
again that was really close but what a
fine effort boy the birthday boy
what a play that was
and he got him what a play what a
stretch again
peters didn't get a hit off hergot
when he hits this ball shark play by
third that's a base hit
soul out racing around second he's into
third they'll throw up the stop sign
a double by dj peters
very nearly tied this game rangers put a
little pressure on here one out the
infield will come in and brock holt
steps in left side of the plate
3-2 from herget and this ball hit well
down the right field line that could be
trouble it bangs off the wall
one run is in here comes peters and the
rangers have their first lead of the
afternoon
holt delivers a two run double and it's
7-6 rangers
they could take a look at the numbers
for joe really good numbers obviously
his 31st game pretty good sample size
opponent's batting average 128. another
chance now the 2-2 pitch and a swing and
a miss he got him barlow with his 11th
save and what a fun win for the rangers
this afternoon they take the finale from
the angels
seven to six
and a little history of course for
adolesce garcia